[Music]
we humans have a knack for changing the
environment often these projects have
effects we didn't plan for its
disastrous and other times it gives us
energy and agriculture but what if we
took the hottest desert in the u.s. and
transformed it into a lake
how would we do it would it help fight
climate change and how would it affect
the people that live there this is what
if and here's what would happen if we
flooded Death Valley Death Valley is the
hottest place on earth with an average
summer temperature of 49 degrees Celsius
it covers 1.3 million hectares of
California and Nevada in the desert
flooding it sounds impossible but Death
Valley periodically floods itself and
south of Death Valley lies the Salton
Sea this freshwater lake was
accidentally created in 1905 when
engineers caused the Colorado River to
flood so was this an environmental boon
or an ecological nightmare
a lake in the middle of a desert sounds
like a great idea but the Salton Sea
revealed a different reality what began
as a freshwater lake is now a toxic and
salty body of water all the fish died
and it smells like rotten eggs why it
had no drainage salt levels increased
oxygen depleted and runoff from
agriculture poisoned the water would the
same thing happen if we flooded Death
Valley well not if we're smart about it
terraforming this area a process of
turning a hostile environment into one
more suitable for human life would
require building a channel from the
Pacific Ocean to Death Valley this would
be about 480 to 650 kilometers long and
would bring water into Death Valley
but what flows in must flow out so we
would need to build a second channel
between Death Valley and the Pacific
Ocean for water to drain this would
avoid the stinky mistake of Salton Sea
by allowing water to move more freely
between the new Death Valley sea and the
Pacific Ocean and there you go water
instead of a desert but what would that
really change well first we'd have to
think of a new name for the area Death
Valley
doesn't seem very appropriate for a
brand new body of water but more
importantly it would be a huge job
creator the venture capital firm Y
Combinator proposed a desert flooding
project in 2018 costing
50 trillion dollars the workers would
need essential services so an economic
boost would spread to surrounding areas
as the channels were built and the new
lakefront property would eventually
bring real estate and tourism small
towns might pop up around the lake
substantially increasing the current
population of 320 people in the area
flooding Death Valley would help in the
fight against climate change
building turbines along the channels
would create renewable energy from water
flow phytoplankton would grow in this
newly created marine environment
reducing the carbon dioxide in the air
it could even offset rising sea levels
by creating space for that water inland
but should we do it while deserts are
usually seen as lifeless expanses they
are important ecosystems and hosts a
variety of different plants and animals
we would be displacing many animals if
we flooded Death Valley so say goodbye
to the famous Roadrunner as well as
Bobcats Gophers and cottontails
these animals would need to find new
homes this becomes a problem when they
decide your backyard looks nice
deserts are also extremely valuable for
mineral production 50% of the world's
copper comes from deserts gypsum borates
nitrates potassium and salts are all
minerals that build up in deserts when
water evaporates lithium an essential
mineral for batteries is found in the
Atacama Desert in Chile electric cars
cellphones and other green technology
wouldn't be possible without it
one third of the planet is covered in
deserts and flooding them is not a new
idea terraforming them into lakes has
been debated for over a century but for
now let's enjoy the beauty and diversity
that deserts like Death Valley or the
Grand Canyon offer us although there are
plans to terraform the entire Sahara
Desert this would require international
collaboration and would have huge
impacts both good and bad around the
world but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]